We've changed our planet
These events have made you the man that you are
They've all imagined
All found
The moon that gravitates
And the sea that falls off
They've been trying to measure the time that gives them
They've offered you all the gifts of happiness
A path to the dreams of humans
Follow your journey to other chimelles
We're going for the vein in the neck. This one here.
The jugular vein. I guess it's where the body's most vulnerable.
Children, if I were you, I wouldn't be too worried. Dogs almost never kill each other.
No wolves come to that.
With men, it's different.
Yes, but man's not an animal.
Man's an animal, all right.
Do I look like some kind of animal? Do I?
Yeah. To me, you look like a wild animal.
I'm saying we humans are animals. I admit we're different, but they're resemblances as well.
Different but the same. How's that possible?
Obviously, we have hearts, a nervous system, reflexes, instincts, same as animals.
And animals are not machines, as was once supposed.
Here's what the great Descartes said.
Animal, it's no more than a machine with its cogs and its springs.
We know exactly what it will do.
Should I pull its tail, it turns its head and barks to clear machine.
Should I pat its head with my hand, it will wag its tail.
It is evidently a spring-like thing linking head and tail.
Pavlov, a Russian scientist, thought animals reacted by reflex.
It is dinner time.
Heard the bell.
Ah, he's accustomed to having dinner when I ring this.
And so all I have to do is ring this little bell and it rules by reflex.
It is simple. Couldn't be simpler.
No, the same. It's not as simple as all that.
Animals are creatures. They're complex with nervous systems.
Some are very intelligent.
To understand them, we have to study their behavior in their environment in nature.
And that's called ethology.
Here we go with the Greeks.
Not at all. For once, it won't be the Greeks.
Ethology is a modern science.
A question, Maestro? Who was it that figured out the thigh logic?
Now, let me see, let me see. There was, well, there was, uh, besides, uh, anyway, the individual who best comprehended animals was surely the Austrian Conrad Lorenz.
Gloria, you're a big nuisance. Impossible to let you be out when I'm working. Go on now, back in your cage. Go on now.
See you later, cage. Mr. Blone, I'll change it.
Goodness, you do want to listen, but I'll admit you've taught me something.
Oh, you should, listen, I...
Many inquisitive active animals cannot bear to be in captivity.
We have to study these creatures and their natural surroundings.
Since you're pregnant, that's not like me.
I don't know, I'm not sure, Father.
I'd also like to study animals.
Oh, you'll be pleased then.
The neighbor's brought back a cockatoo, but it's very sad.
Kept in a cage?
Of course.
That's why it's sad.
Oh, Conrad, as if you have enough already.
What will you do with it?
Well, to begin with, I'll release it, and then we'll see.
But no, thanks, I'm not hungry.
This, of many animals, is similar in many ways to man's. This is clearly observed.
He's got gosh.
Guy, big and strong.
Wonder if he's with anyone.
Show him.
He got pretty eyes, sweetheart.
Do you like him?
You see, Margaret, when jackdaws marry, it's for life, and they always stay faithful.
Just like humans.
Just as you say, Margaret, yes, just as you say.
Do we ought to think about making a nest?
Sure, sweetheart.
We'll be fine here.
This is my place. It's reserved.
No, it's mine. Watch it. I'm bigger than you and stronger.
Oh, you think so? Well, we'll just see about that.
Pair each other to pieces. Separate them.
No, Margaret. They won't even hurt each other.
You'll see. We'll have plenty of time to pick strawberries.
You see? They're still here, but they're now really fatigued.
Wait, you'll see.
This place, I'll find a better one.
I won. I won because I was bigger and stronger.
Whoa.
You see? And humans behave in the same way.
We would frighten enemies, but we don't want to fight.
We might be injured.
Watch them.
Stole my spade.
No!
He stole my pitchfork.
He stole it and it was him.
No, it was him.
You were up in my back.
Hold me.
Glad that you're here.
You took your time.
Calm down, young man.
There's no hurry.
Are you up there?
Uh-huh.
Young man.
Baby.
Doing very well.
Mother is too.
It's a little loud.
That's what you got.
See the little jackdaw.
Right.
It should be flying by now.
They're ready.
You show them how.
It's there, but they don't appear to be too worried.
They don't realize it's an animal dangerous for them.
They have to be taught.
Oh, how?
Look there.
It's strange.
The jackdaws don't recognize their enemies instinctively, then.
No, they learn.
The parents have to teach them.
But they attack instinctively when they think one of theirs is being attacked.
Here, watch this.
Did you see?
The dark object I was holding in my hand, they thought that I was holding a bird.
But now it's over.
They trust me again.
You see?
No, animals are not simple machines.
They can be sad or happy.
They're able to learn behavior and even love.
They may even develop a true affection for a person.
You see, Alfred, these small goslings have known me since birth
and follow me as if I was their own mother.
You see, these ducks don't accept me.
Why's that?
I think it's because the mallards have their own special call.
I've observed that.
They have to hear it at birth if they're going to adopt anyone.
Here, let's give it a try. Come on.
Why do they follow anymore?
It's because now you're too tall. Bend down.
He's such a nice man, too.
The man imagines he's a duck, but I don't suppose he's dangerous.
You better watch him. You can never tell.
It's incredible, not unlike mothers. They follow us around.
Ducks are tame. The geese, too. They're all mine.
The jockdaws are, too.
Birds are here for everybody. Right to shoot them.
I wonder, would you pass me my scarf there?
He's hunted by the prey he hunts.
He's talking a lot of nonsense, all that ducks.
In my opinion, it's a lesson worth learning.
A lesson, eh? What lesson?
You're on my prom.
Shotgun. Shotgun.
See, you encroach the National Guard, the Cavalry.
I'll sue you. You just wait. You're both...
These animals around, I'm worried about the baby.
I wonder if we put the animals in cages.
They go to their cages at night.
Have to feel they're free.
But you gave me a good idea.
Do you really think all the animals will go in?
No, they won't.
But we certainly can.
Turned upside down.
Animals are feeding the humans.
You detangle my wool.
Say it, the Lorenz's are a little bit crazy.
Chimney Seep was an enemy.
He's going to be lost.
That's him.
He's drunk, he is.
Look, he's on his shoulders.
People have all kinds of wrong ideas about animals.
Take wolves.
How many times do you hear these animals are wild and cruel?
They're really quite different.
They hunt only to survive.
Hunts are hungry.
We haven't eaten for three days.
All except the young ones.
The one we go for, but be careful.
Kill a wolf with one kick of their hooves.
Softly.
Same reason dogs, which as you know are related to wolves,
only very rarely kill each other.
I wouldn't say it's science, 'cause me, too.
I always look at the animals.
Just the other day, I saw a great cat, another one.
Just looking, watching, it takes far more.
You have to observe, compare, theorize.
Then it's a science.
You remember, Democritus studied a grain of sand and he broke it and deduced the idea of atoms.
Galileo observed the moon, the sun, and the planets.
The theorist, he figured out the movement of the heavenly bodies.
Newton, an apple, fell on his head.
He comes up with laws of gravitation.
Faraday liked watching lightning.
And what was the result?
The laws of electromagnetism.
That is real science.
Lawrence, too, observed, in his case, animals.
He saw they had personalities.
And he devised certain laws that apply to all sorts of animal behavior patterns,
even applicable to humans.
For instance, animals of the same species rarely kill each other.
You reject, like me.
Human beings, too, deep down, still remains of that primitive brain we inherited from the animals.
No doubt there is the command, you shall not kill your own species.
But when life becomes really too difficult,
when animals are confined to a limited environment,
There are too many of them, there's too little to live on, then their aggression takes over, with animals and with people.
Well, there's ambition, and there's pride, and, well, these feelings are unknown to the animals.
It's become too easy to kill, letting others do it for us, come up with good reasons for bad actions, killing, but not knowing who, anonymous, abstract.
As Conrad Lawrence has tried to teach us, we should perhaps return to the good sense of the animals.
It's a good thing.